then there was the game that was tucked
into the late afternoon window
second tier to cowboy steelers which
actually ended up being a better game
than we would have imagined but that got
that was the tony romo jim nance game
but it was
kyler murray
against tuatanga viloa for the first
time and they won't get together again
for four more years unless they meet in
the super bowl and who knows maybe they
will
but that was an exciting game the
dolphins pull off the victory
to 31 i would say that tua's audition
went pretty well on sunday got an
incomplete week one he got an a plus for
week two here's kyle murray after the
game though not happy
with the outcome in his first ever nfl
meeting
against tua
tyler this is really a tough loss for
you guys at home how do you process this
and how do you move forward from here
uh
hold on um
yeah
it's gonna be better we came out here
and laid in an egg
um
i don't know but
uh
we gotta be better
hey
look i i love kyler and
he's not used to losing
he he
even last year when
the cardinals were much worse than they
are this year and they went through some
growing pains early he you know he
didn't want to accept losing that's the
thing we see these great college
quarterbacks come to the nfl and they
realize
you will lose games you will lose games
it doesn't matter who you are look at
tom brady last night you will lose games
you will get blown out from time to time
yeah that's what makes the winds all
that more memorable and something to
cherish and get excited and dance in the
locker room over but yeah great players
are all over the place and
and uh
you know every time it feels like the
cardinals are
really starting to take off right that's
when they that's when they hit that
ceiling and they come up against
somebody that knows how to slow them
down now 31 points isn't nearly slowing
them down but that's what makes the
dolphin so fascinating right now if they
need to score points with tua they can
but they also can create points with
their defense and they can slow you down
with their defense they're not going to
slow everyone down you can't slow down
kyler but you can still outscore him and
that's what the dolphins were able to do
chris yeah that's right i mean you know
they did a a good job on kyler
especially early on in the football game
uh but kyler is just a phenomenal
specimen of a player he's he's really
it's hard to bottle him up
i don't know what else to say
i mean again i mean his acceleration and
his ability to
oh
i'm in the pocket
here's a little seam for me to hit
and go zero to 103 steps and then some
of the cool quarterback design runs that
they had for kyler murray yesterday too
i mean they were well thought out i mean
he's tough to defend you know he will
make the defenses have to do things they
don't want to do but because it's kyla
murray he really forces the issue that
way hey dolphins made a play early on
but after that it was a shootout to to a
degree and and tua to bring it to him i
mean yeah that was great to see it
really was because we didn't get to see
anything in week one
but the dolphins doing things too that
really fit him and his game and also
just a good way to bring him along early
on in his career i mean anybody who
watched the game yesterday it was only
three things he did he threw screens
every now and then but bootlegs and he's
because he's great throwing on the run
and he's athletic that way and then
just go routes down the sideline because
he's got great touch and feel to put the
ball in the right spot whether that's
preston williams or davonte parker or
whatever to go up and get the ball and
that's really what they did they've kind
of made the game simple that way hey
he's a young quarterback let's run the
football just a little oh they're trying
to stop the run we'll run the boots oh
we have one on one out here he's got
good field to throw back shoulders or
lead the guy down the field or throw it
up 50 50 wise let's not make the game
complicated and i think that's you know
emboldened him too mike you know to feel
like okay i'm in the rhythm of the game
and then he started to make plays that
were off schedule as the game went on we
saw some of those cool runs that helped
them win the football game ultimately
four straight wins since uh starting the
season at uh one and two and actually
they were o and two so they're five and
one yeah since back-to-back losses to
afc east rivals and look they gave the
seahawks everything they could handle
they beat the 49ers they beat the rams
they beat the cardinals they're three in
one chris against the nfc west the best
division supposedly in football the
dolphins have almost entirely owned them
uh and the doll and their losses
you know patriots week one cam newton we
haven't seen this offense before
buffalo bills who
yeah this just in they're not the best
team in football but they're damn good
they're six and two and just stomped on
the seattle seahawks who a lot of people
got in the super bowl in the nfc
and then you know the other the other
and then you know of course they lost to
seattle in a close football game where
it was there to be had so there's a lot
to like again the team this is why they
made the move it wasn't about
auditioning to it at any point no they
drafted two or they wanted to work they
hired an offensive coordinator
that
it makes sense with him and tua and
everything about it so there is
something
there to be had
but like we talked about when they made
the switch they made the switch because
they said damn we're kind of getting
good and we could maybe go on a run here
and we don't want to end up being nine
and three and then trying to have a
conversation about
what do we do should we pull the plug on
ryan fitzpatrick or tua and then it's
just a disaster so they did the right
thing here and yet they've managed to
still win two games with tool while
bringing him along and that goes to the
credit to change and brian flores and
everything they're doing down there i
mean miami is one of those teams right
now that you just put stars next to
their organization they've made all the
right moves the last two years and uh
can't say enough good things about them
and five assistant coaches weren't
available yesterday for brian flores
because they landed on the covet 19
reserve list uh as the nfl continues to
be extra sensitive with its protocols
let's let's go ahead and get the bingo
ready control room i don't care next
week it's tua vs justin herbert how
about that chris now the chargers are
desperate
thank you the chargers are desperate but
they are not horrible uh at denver the
following week at the jets
cincinnati bengals and joe burrow
coming up week 13 are you kidding me
kansas city chiefs and patrick mahomes
then a rematch with the patriots at the
raiders and at the bills
and when you consider what they've done
the last month of the season
i think the dolphins are in great
position down the stretch to challenge
the bills atop the division and at a
minimum chris to get a wild card berth
and help seal the deal that the patriots
aren't getting in this year yeah that
could be the the final force for the
patriots you're right i mean it could
come down to that week 15 matchup with
new england but i know when you look at
the schedule there you sit there and you
go
there they most likely will be favorites
in the next what four games
they have a chance to be sitting here in
a few weeks nine and three i mean they
really do we'll see where it goes but
they got a lot of things to like about
their football team and there are a lot
of things on that football team that are
playoff caliber too this is not just
like you know as we've mentioned some
team that got lucky or so the schedule
fell right and they got to play all
these teams where yeah they match up
well or the teams aren't good or their
best player got hurt they've had none of
that you know there is there is
redeeming qualities across the roster
let alone good coaching and they're here
to stay and not just this year but get
used to it because miami i think's here
for the next few years with what you
know chris greer and brian flores have
done as far as flipping this team around
and over and all the young players they
got on the team right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports